so in this time
whether we look at the time of fascism
or we look at the fictional animal farm
what's the heroic action then so uh
camus joined the communist party there's
a bunch of different heroic actions
some more heroic than others not just
for the
you know heroes the wrong word in terms
of like effectiveness sure what's the
effective action i guess is what i want
to
ask as a writer as a thinker somebody
with a mind
what's the heroic action that's a tricky
question because a lot of times in the
west heroism
is regardless intertwined with martyrdom
right so it's kind of this idea of like
you have to speak to
you know kemu always talked about just
let justice be done though the heavens
fall
this is a common um kind of motto among
people with conscience
and that you have to do the right thing
even the consequences might not be what
you like
and i think that is a good loose
definition of heroism
so if you me i'll give you one example
of heroism this was on twitter and i
really feel bad that i don't remember
the guy's name
this was the line to auschwitz i believe
it was and you know there's the nazi
guards keeping everyone along
and if you were a cert i think if you
were under 12 they killed you or some
there was some age limit where
some kids were killed or some were not
there were some circumstances
and he asked the mom how old this kid
was and she's like he's 14 and she's
like no he's 12. and she's like no he's
nice 14 she goes
he's 12. and she realized what this nazi
was telling her even in that
circumstance
and it ended up saving the kids life so
i think heroism
in this context is defiance
and standing true to values of
liberalism
humanism and uh venerating the sanctity
of human life i think that uh and
i think it's also important to pick your
battles
uh i don't think if you know he got that
nazi over there gotten a bullhorn
and said hey this is the rules blah blah
blah that's not going to help anyone do
anything so i do think
you know people a lot of times attack me
for my anarchist views it's like oh
you know would you call the police would
you use the roads would you pay your
income taxes
uh you know i i got an argument with tim
poole because there was that couple i
think it was at missouri or illinois
when they
had their guns and they were being
arrested and they basically took a plea
deal
and he said you should have fought i go
it's a lot easier to say you should
fight but we don't know what
circumstance someone is under
and what these totalitarian regimes did
very very well as
as you know is if you were a target
and they can't get through to you that's
fine you have a family
so you can sit there lex and gird your
jaw
and you can stand up to all the torture
cool what are we going to do about your
wife
what about your mom one thing stalin did
he made it a law
that kids up to uh 14 and up could get
the death penalty for certain crimes
so after that the rule was from the nkvd
if you were interrogating someone they
would have death warrants
for the kid's child on the desk visible
so i'm interrogating you
asking you to uh commit to i'm sorry to
admit to some crime
that you're not committed and those
piece of paper it's you know svetlana
she's got a death warrant you're gonna
admit to any crime you want
so this is something americans this is
even the case right now in north korea
um which i know you had yami park on
it's something i talk about a lot let's
talk about instead of the hypothetical
but this is happening
right now on earth you can look at the
map on google
uh the great leader kim il-sung the
founder of north korea said class
enemies must be exterminated three
generations
so north when people talk about
individualism versus collectivism
uh rick santorum former senator says the
family is the basic unit of
society unit north korea takes that
seriously the family is punished as a
unit
so if someone does something wrong three
generations have the pay the price
and you often don't know who it is that
got you all in trouble there's not a
trial
this to western minds is something
almost incomprehensible it's a lot
easier to be brave
when it's just your skin there's
something when it's when it's
yeah when it's your child your your
loved ones
your every man becomes a coward but also
what bravery is there for me to write an
essay for the guardian to say i don't
vote there's no consequences to me
there's no possibility of consequences
to me this is the wonderful thing about
living excuse me in a free country
uh it would take a lot of courage to be
in the soviet union and say i'm not
going to vote and
what would that courage accomplish uh
very little so i think heroism in the
sense of kind of the suicidal stuff and
taking a stance with no consequences is
a bit overrated
there is some aspect like the way i
think about heroism
is something like you said about the
nazi soldier
which is quietly privately in your own
life
live the virtues that you want the rest
of the world to live by
yes so like without like writing about
it
is um it's not as heroic as living it
quietly
i'll give you a great example of this i
sometimes give talks on networking
and i tell the kids if you know
someone's in town
and it's their birthday with nothing to
do take them out and i say i do this for
selfish reasons and everyone laughs and
i go think about it this way
the guy who takes people out for their
birthday
is awesome that could be you like you
have that capacity
to be that person and you're making that
day feel special they're going to
remember for a long time
what's the cost dinner 30 bucks 25 bucks
so
they're it's it's very disturbing to me
how often people have opportunities
to slightly move the needle and make
things a bit better
at almost no cost and they just
literally don't think in those terms
and one of the things camus talked about
you know he's often described as a
existentialist which he did not like
that term he regarded himself as an
absurdist
is the idea that we're basically blank
canvases and this isn't something that
is dangerous this is enormous
opportunity
and you have the ability to become the
kind of man or woman
that you admire and want to be you don't
have to be you know
i don't know george washington or one of
these great heroes of all time
but everyone out there has the capacity
capacity excuse me to be a hero to their
kids or to be a hero to maybe
some there's there's nursing homes and
there's old people who are lonely
i think that you take in a dog that's on
its last legs
uh uh these are little things terry
shepard does that a lot out of regard as
a hero
um these are not terry shepard on
blanket's name
these are things that people do um that
aren't heroic in the sense of superman
but that i find admirable extremely and
i think are very underrated because
these people aren't championed
is this some kind of weird
passive-aggressive and direct way
for you to tell me that i should take
you off for your birthday on monday
is that why you gave that whole speech
that's that wasn't it at all
that was a joke michael no it was a
failed joke
nevertheless there was no punch line
without failure we would not have
triumph
you